ja ich sag ja wir brauchen einfach mehr
politiker die auch ihren eigenen ihre
eine meinung richtig bringen es gibt ja
in den koalitionen in den fraktionen
halt oft auch so eine meinung die man
vertritt muss und da muss ich einfach
sagen wir brauchen einfach wieder leute
die einfach eine klare kante zeigen und
die genau das aufzeigen ich weiß
eigentlich schon wir haben ja insgesamt
sollen glaube ich wir waren das ich
glaube bis
2030 15 millionen e-autos bis 2030
geschaffen werden dafür brauchen wir
also es werden zurzeit 250 meilen pro
monat pro woche erschafft und wir
brauchen 2000 euro pro woche das
erreichen wir also das weiß ich jetzt
schon warum macht man das ich möchte
einfach eine realistische politik die
vielleicht nicht ganz so schnell ist
aber ich nehme meine bürgern und bürger
mit das ist das entscheidende ich muss
unsere unseren bürger mitnehmen und muss
versuchen auch ein bisschen umzusetzen
und das fehlt mir in vielen bereichen
weil dann auch ja in den parteien auch
immer so ein proporz herrscht da kommen
wir auch nachher nochmal drauf sehr
einfach nicht gut ist sondern ich möchte
einfach eine ehrliche politik und der
realistische politik und die vermisse
ich in vielen bereichen frau bald
vermissen sie die auch in frische
ehrliche politik ja ich zum beispiel als
kleinunternehmer bin mit zwölf
angestellten drei bis fünf millionen
euro umsatz ich habe eine administration
ich habe eine bürokratie ich habe bis
ich meine steuererklärung gemacht habe
die kostet mich erstmal 40.000 euro im
jahr und kostet mich sehr viel zeit
ungehörige würde dein frischer ehrlicher
politikstil helfen der setzt da an wo es
klemmt und
natürlich pandemie krieg inflation die
ganzen großen themen aber der bürger im
detail muss man spüren was man für ihn
tut wie man ihn entlastet mit dem ganzen
nun bis jetzt 20 euro 300 euro da so ein
unfug man muss hingehen
2500 brutto 3500 brutto die leute
einfach von der lohnsteuer entlasten ja
dem thema kommen wir das auch noch
später die frage die ich mir auch stelle
gibt es denn ein politiker wo sie sagen
der ist gut den guten ehrlichen politik
alles roger
ich habe noch andere ausdrücke aber es
kommen nun aber ich hab mal wieder dass
jetzt etwas oder ich habe in meinen
glückwunsch aussprechen nachdem für die
tollkühnheit dass sie jetzt als cdu nah
dieses plädoyer halten 16 jahre lang
unter merkel war die cdu der inbegriff
einer kaderpartei die parteitage waren
krönungsmesse für die heilige angela ist
wo dahinten gestoppt wie lang man
klatscht man musste ganz langen
klatschen die arme konnten einem abfall
aber hauptsache es war ein einer
klatsche gott es wurde einheit
hergestellt ist war kritik an der
königin absoluter angela der ersten von
der uckermark war verpönt es wurden
ganze karrieren beendet wenn wir nicht
im richtigen moment seine eine huldigung
adressen erbracht
habe 16 jahre lang war glaube ich die
cdu eine programmatisch nahezu tote oder
zumindest diskussion vl partei geworden
und die schlechten ergebnisse am ende
sind meines erachtens auch dieser
umstand geschuldet als da muss sich
fundamental was ändern wenn speziell in
ihrer partei der wirklich jetzt das
frische das ehrliche das neue
politisieren ausbrechen soll aber ein
mitglied
aber erst müssen auch mal hell wir haben
ja auch gedacht das geht so weiter hat
die
zwei jahre hat man die basis nicht
mitgenommen geheim und sich von anderen
vorsitzenden entschieden oder erst eine
vorsitzenden vorwissen entschieden die
basis heute von vornherein eigentlich
märz sie haben das ja von unten und das
habe ich ja wollte söder und entlastet
so und er hat man das dort auch wieder
wie früher immer so durchgezogen haben
es geht nicht mehr basis spielt nicht
mehr mit und das meint nicht die was
will eigentlich auch die basis der cdu
mitgliedern und mitglieder die möchten
einfach auch wieder in frischen klaren
ehrlichen hat den markus söder in
frischen ehrlichen klaren wind oder
friedrich merz das glaube ich schon er
hat auf jeden fall zurzeit die partei
wir haben eine richtung und ich finde er
macht das auch bei den debatten stellte
auch die regierung sehr gut und insofern
bin ich da ganz überrascht war ich war
eigentlich von vornherein für friedrich
merz aber ich bin froh dass wir haben
aber daniel günther der die wahl in
schleswig holstein gewonnen hat war auch
einer der quasi stärksten merkel
unterstützer der auch mit aktiv daran
gearbeitet hat dass herr merz vielleicht
in diesen zwei jahren nicht mehr werden
das heißt am ende des tages die leute
die hinter diesem system wie es sich
unter der bundeskanzlerin an der merkel
entwickelt hat standen und das
mitgemacht haben sind ja nach wie vor da
jawohl herr merz jetzt vorsitzender ist
heißt das ja nicht dass die cdu sich
komplett gewandelt hat dass die
mandatsträger lich auch da sein aber ich
sage ihnen folgendes ich glaube dass wir
jetzt in der tat
und das merken in diesem jahr auch schon
in eine andere form der debatte
miteinander konnten in der debatte die
in letzten 16 jahren so nicht möglich
weiß wird gestritten es war zeit
zwischen den parteien die debatten im
bundestag sind ganz anders als davor
ganz einfach deswegen weil
union jetzt in der opposition hat
position komplett relativiert wie sie
davor halt vertreten hat in der region
mich als bürger interessiert immer nicht
so sehr dieser oppositions kampflos über
teilen gerne was mich eher interessiert
ist hermann finden sie denn politik hals
zu abgehoben dass sie nicht mehr bei den
bürgern die bei mir sind nein das glaube
ich nicht ich glaube das ganz ganz viele
politiker ganz egal ob in landtagen im
bundestag auch im europäischen parlament
sehr engagiert für ihre sache eintreten
für ihre unterbunden hatte wusste nicht
mal teuer
für ihre inhalte das ist natürlich so
ist das mitunter
ab einer gewissen ebene vielleicht diese
bodenhaftung bei dem ein oder anderen
verloren geht das ist so und das muss
man ja das kommt auf den jeweils
einzelnen an das kann man glaube ich so
nicht also frau merkel zum beispiel war
sicherlich sehr bodenständig ja wenn man
sie irgendwie wieder einzupacken die
ebene an ja deswegen sage ich ja es
kommt auf den einzelnen personen darauf
an nicht auf so und deswegen kann man
das so pauschal nicht sagen ich weigere
mich nur dagegen so eine pauschale
verurteilung der politiker dadurch ist
als kaste zu tun wenn jemand abgehoben
ist dann muss man das kritisieren muss
sie noch stellen dass auch eine aufgabe
in der tat denn in den fraktionen nur
parteien das entsprechend zu adressieren
ich glaube da sind wir alle einig so zu
tun als ob das nicht möglich ist finde
ich etwas übertrieben natürlich haben
wir einen fraktionsdisziplin in den
einzelnen parteien wenn es um abstimmung
geht das ist richtig da muss sich jeder
genau überlegen ob er den kompromiss
bereit mitzugehen einer koalition aber
alles in allem kann ich nicht sagen dass
das system in deutschland nicht
funktioniert im gegenteil man muss ja
sagen bei allem was schlecht läuft wenn
wir uns angucken wie es in anderen
europäischen ländern läuft sind wir doch
noch immer relativ stadt nicht aber wir
hatten eine wahlbeteiligung in nrw ich
glaube 550 ist ein garni arosa minister
und dann höre ich mir dann höre ich mir
dort die wahlprogramme an und dann wird
wird zum beispiel die spd einsatz nur
mit dem slogan glaube ich mit euch
gewinnen wird das morgen nach was das
für uns flogen also wenn die politik nur
noch ein produkt ist wenn es keine
direkte ansprache ist sie auch jeder
versteht und nicht nur hyper ironisch
oder für die ganze laboriert und dass
irgendein berliner werbeagentur hat darf
ich finde ich wohin wenn die leute zu
hause bleibt wird sagen mit ihr würde
ich das morgen nicht gewinnen jetzt
mache ich schon heute in deutschland
geht es relativ gut dies wie die jahre
mit frau merkel waren auch super mit
kohl auch aber die zukunft da habe ich
echt so der hallenser
die arbeit liegt im detail das ist
genauso wie meinem business retail ist
detail ja du musst ja gucken was da
läuft was kommt beim bürger an und
selbst also ich bin jetzt auch
interessiert an politik da war ich immer
schon aber nur ein hauch ich muss mich
mal meinem business kümmern ich kann
mich ein bisschen aus mittel steuer ich
weiß auch was das ganze bedeutet dieses
was ihr euch da zusammenbraut
händische durch und und dieses
kartenhaus für heute die milliarden
gehen einfach so raus im stundentakt er
soll ja ich meine nein wir sollten davon
halten 100 milliarden schulden in
sondervermögen ja und wie auch immer
angeblich ist das deutsche militär
genauso gut oder schlecht wie frankreich
oder großbritannien ist also die
situation dass die deutsche bundeswehr
trete ich mal das kommt in den
nachrichten ist es alles fake news heute
mir der rhein zieht den lieben langen
tag höher wohnt um die uhr diese
nachrichten diese dieses dauerschlaf wie
sie es endlich kapiert habe und
inhaliert hat und rita stimmt dass der
freigegeben wurden keine fake news also
aber wir müssen
erstmal so dass erst mal sind es
momentan kreditermächtigungen die
irgendwann den in der tat in schulden
einen verbindlichkeiten umgewandelt
werden aber die feststellung dass die
bundeswehr in einem desolaten zustand
ist und dass wir spätestens seit dem
angriff russlands auf die ukraine hier
ein massives sicherheitsproblem
müssen das teilen alle parteien gar
nicht dass du deswegen diesen scheinbar
sieht das anders sie sieht aus
sondervermögen schulden und
verbindlichkeiten ja erstmal auch dass
diese 100 milliarden euro freigegeben
werden müssen damit die bundeswehr tätig
werden kann die unsere grenzen zu
verteilen die haben ja hier wirklich
einmal ganz gerne ein haken und zweiter
der etat für die bundeswehr das hören
wir mal wie im was für diese ladezustand
wir sind wenn man dann vergleicht
beispielsweise mit dem italien russland
ausgibt für die armee gehen gar nicht so
wenig aus als ob ich jetzt entstand in
der öffentlichkeit das wie einfach nie
was ausgegeben bestimmt nicht wieder
fast gleichauf mit russland das sind die
frage ein herr dohrendorf von der union
16 jahre war die union die
regierungspartei da ist jetzt meine
frage wie kann es denn sein dass wir
jetzt immer in der in der gesellschaft
darüber reden wir haben kein geld für
die bundeswehr wir hatten ja geld es
wurde nur alles ehrlich gesagt
beschissen ausgegeben naja also kann man
es ja auch nicht sagen also wir wollten
ja schon aufrüsten in vielen bereichen
nur wenn man in einer koalition ist dann
müssten guten job gemacht was die bundes
eintrag aber wenn sie wenn sie die
mehrheit nicht haben können sie nicht
durchsetzen so einfach ist also wenn die
koalition das merken wir jetzt ja in der
parteiengeschichte auch bei der ampel
die erste hat einfach nicht mitgespielt
die hat einfach das war wir haben ja
öfter die anträge gestellt dass die
bundeswehr stärker aufgerüstet werden
das ist ja nicht erst jetzt bekannt
sondern schon seit vielen jahren und die
ganze beschaffung ist doch desolat
gewesen unter cdu-verteidigungsminister
ganze
gerede über effizientes gelten ich sage
aber hinten sagen auch entschuldigung
dass ich unterbreche ich bin auch
verfechter verfechter zum beispiel dass
ich oben jemand in der spitze haben
möchte der ist im bereich vielleicht
schon mal tätig war denn gedient hat der
oder oder formal kellerei war der weiß
wovon er spricht er so ein wichtiges
thema so ein existenzielles thema was
wir ja nun auch gerade feststellen durch
den krieg das dass wir da sag ich jetzt
mal die kommen noch einmal zur kranke
frauenquote ist man darf wirklich ich
habe kein problem mit einer frau
direkt ja verteidigungsministerin ist
die aber dann wirklich schon mal in der
bundeswehr irgendetwas gemacht hat die
ein bisschen sich auskennen das ist auch
dafür die für die soldatinnen und
soldaten
noch keine atomwaffen oder der kümmert
haben wir vielleicht die neuesten panzer
bewachten über drohnen und 20 gesund ist
und woher sind meter turm waren sie
atomwaffen und aber welche einen auf der
anderen seite hat mache ich entweder zu
überholen
es ist und wir haben ja die nato das ist
ein verteidigungsbündnis da gibt es mit
amerika gibt es mitglieder die
atomwaffen besitzen und wir haben gerade
unter anderem beschlossen dass nicht
beschlossen aber der bundeskanzler als
angekündigt dass wir unter dem stichwort
nukleare teilhabe
kampfflugzeuge anschaffen die in der
lage sind amerikanische atomwaffen auch
was sie im ernstfall zu nutzen deswegen
glaube ich am ende des tages müssen wir
feststellen die bundeswehr hat zwei
probleme zum einen ist sie von der
beschaffung her desolat aufgestellt das
muss geändert werden das liegt unter
anderem an den berühmten goldstandard in
deutschland den letzten jahren immer
haben wollte in ganz ganz vielen
bereichen und zum anderen müssen wir
feststellen dass die vergleichbarkeit
zum beispiel mit russland doch nicht
ganz so einfach geht weil russland
natürlich sehr viel mehr geld in die
ausrüstung gesteckt hat und weniger in
den sold der soldaten werde das bei uns
glücklicherweise anders ist und deswegen
müssen wir entsprechend mehr ausgeben
das tun wir jetzt und das wird ein paar
jahre dauern hoch hochlauf aber dann
werden wir dieses thema zumindest
erledigt werden dann bleiben und zu
schauen wie die bundesregierung das mit
der bundeswehr managed wie die fdp es
nennt und die anderen parteien